bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
comment vous accueillez la prolongation
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire a jusqu'au
24 juillet et elle est pas tellement
surprenante parce qu'on sait que on est
à un moment de fragilité de notre
société on ne sait pas du tout si il va
y avoir cette fameuse deuxième vague ou
non
on sait très bien qu'il n'ya pas de
vaccin qu'il n'y a pas de traitement
il ya une très faible partie de la
population est immunisé et que donc tout
est à craindre si les mesures barrières
ne sont pas respectés par la population
et si la population n'est pas mise en
capacité de faire ces mesures barrières
je veux dire par là que la population
n'ait pas les moyens de protection il va
falloir que les masques sont mis à la
disposition de la population et que les
solutés hydro-alcooliques que soit
également présents notamment dans les
milieux recevant du public dans les
transports en commun etc
je crois que l'on repousse cela on
l'emmène tient de deux mois cet état
d'urgence mais pas de façon à pouvoir
réagir si tenté qu'il y avait à remettre
en place malheureusement un confinement
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
il a dit qu'il fallait apprendre à vivre
avec le virus voilà l'enjeu des
prochains mois qu'en pensez vous ça
c'est les séries
malheureusement la partie de nos vies ça
veut dire qu'on va changer notre façon
de travailler on va changer notre façon
de circuler
on va changer notre façon de vivre
puisque à chaque instant il va falloir
que l'on observe ces fameuses mesures
barrières de façon à ne pas prendre le
risque de diffuser la maladie puisque
l'on sait qu'il y a une grande part de
cas asymptomatiques c'est à dire qu'il a
une grande part de gens qui peuvent être
porteurs de la maladie sans même le
savoir et donc vecteurs de la maladie
sans même le savoir donc oui la
contacter ce virus va faire partie de
nos vies malheureusement ni bord pendant
plusieurs mois
sauf si sauf si tu es heureux il y avait
une saisonnalité c'est à dire qu'il
disparaissait pendant la période chaude
parmi les mesures la mise en quarantaine
et d'isolement 1 qui seront obligatoires
que pour les personnes arrivant sur le
territoire national quel est l'intérêt
du
telle mesure était d'une telle mesure
c'est d'éviter que des gens porteurs de
la maladie rentrer sur le territoire
national et dissémine la maladie donc il
faut qu'on les teste
il faut que si ces tests sont positifs
qu'on puisse les isoler les copines et
de façon à ce qu'il guérisse de la
maladie évidemment qu'on les prennent un
soin en était besoin
et puis qu'il guérisse et qu'on puisse à
ce moment là les faire sortir et
circuler sur le territoire national ça
c'est ncc scholar est peut-être mal fait
lors de la phase peu près filmant alors
lundi le sénat va examiner ce projet de
loi mais lundi aussi les masques ont
arrivés massivement dans les grandes
surfaces et la polémique autour des
masques qui continue qui enfle puisque
nombre de vos confrères dénonce
justement ce cet accord passé avec le
gouvernement et la grande distribution
quelle est votre lecture des choses que
c'est un potentiel scandale dans le
scandale dans le scandale dans le
scandale en irlande au tj gagnez vous
savez qu'on découvre un scandale sous un
scandale c'est un scandale ce qu'on
demande est très claire on l'a dit dès
l'instant où monsieur vont pas à parler
sur une chaîne concurrente à la vôtre on
a demandé immédiatement à ce que pour
lever toute ambiguïté le bon de commande
la facture le bon de livraison soit
rendue publique
moi j'entends les ministres cantonaux
dit mais non c'était pas des commandes
c'est ce ce ne sont pas les huit en
stock ce sont juste des commandes
il n'ya pas les grandes surfaces n'ont
pas réellement ces masques il a logist
10 millions nous des types qui est
inutile 5 millions à voix basse on
rappelle que 5 billion c'est le 'gap'
au-dessus duquel vous pouvez
réquisitionné donc là évidemment à 5
millions ils ne sont pas réquisitionna
bhl et puis l'audi on a distribué plus
de 100 millions de masques aux soignants
vont les a pas vus arriver je vous dis
tout de suite
nous on reçoit un gros douze masques
chirurgicaux et de temps en temps si
masques ffp2 d'autres semaine 18 masques
chirurgicaux il arrive parfois qu'on
reçoit encore des masques périmés donc
on n'a pas vraiment vu cette hausse très
importante de masques que le ministère
semble nous avons donné et puis il a dit
que ce week-end se sont ils à les ouvrir
je mange les stocks pourra distribuer un
peu plus aux soignants est ce que c'est
en rapport avec ce scandale sous jacent
de techno façon plus le demande mais en
tout cas j'en termine en tout cas de
façon encore une fois à lever
l'ambiguïté et puis parce qu'il n'y a
pas de concurrence et puisque les prix
vont être plafonnés on demanderait ce
que le bon de commande le point de
livraison
la facture soit rendue publique pour
intermarché pour carrefour pour les taux
et pour le caire merci beaucoup
j'ai remarqué je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin et président du syndicat à deux
médecins eurent fait merci à vous